مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في تغطيه ثاني اكبر
زلزال يضرب تركيا خلال 100 عام وتغطيات
مباشره لاثار الزلزال العنيف والمدمر الذي
ضرب جنوب تركيا وشمال سوريا اخر الارقام
المتعلقه باعداد القتلى تتحدث عن اكثر من
700 قتيل في سوريا و912 في تركيا والحصيله
في تزايد وتكبر وتزيد خلال الدقائق وفيما
تتواصل عمليات الانقاذ التي تزيد من
صعوبتها العاصفه التي تضرب بالتزامن هذه
المنطقه عاصفه ثلجيه درجات حراره صفريه
اعلنت الكوارث التركيه تسجيل زلزال ثاني
مركزه ايضا كهرمان مرعش بقوه 7.6 درجه
الزلزال المدمر الاول الذي وقع فجرا ضرب
جنوب تركيا ومناطق تسيطر عليها المعارضه
والمكتظه بنحو اربعه ملا السوري نجحوا من
مناطق اخرى من البلاد بسبب الحرب الاهليه
وافاد اعلام النظام مشاهدينا اعلام النظام
السوري بان زلزالا ضرب العاصمه السوريه
دمشق وهزات اقتداديه في مدينه اللاذقيه
وذكر مراسل العربيه ايضا ان الوضع
الانساني طبعا في شمال سوريا ماساوي جدا
وبسبب نقص الامكانات وان المؤسسات الطبيه
في شمال سوريا غير قادره على التعامل مع
نوعيه هذه الاصابات طبعا الجهات الفاعله
في شمال سوريا اعلنت ان المنطقه منطقه
منكوبه وقال ناشطون في مناطق المعارضه
السوريه ان عائلات باكملها محاصره تحت
انقاذ المباني المنهاره المرصد السوري
تحدث واشار عن مئات القتلى ومصير مجهول
يواجه المئات مشيرا ان 58 قريه وبلده في
شمال سوريا شهدت انهيارات كليه او جزئيه
للمباني وان حجم الكارثه او كارثه الزلزال
يفوق الامكانات متوفره في شمال سوريا
الزلزال المدمر مشاهدينا الذي ضرب تركيا
صباح اليوم كنا ثاني اقواز زلزال يضرب
البلاد منذ عام
1939 حيث بلغت قوه الهزه الارضيه صباح
اليوم اكثر من سبعه درجه حوالي 7.7 تحديدا
وشعر بها عدد من الدول المجاوره في مكانه
مركز
الزلزال قهرمان مرعش الواقعه شمال مدينه
غازي عنتاب في منطقه تبعد حوالي 90
كيلومترا عن حدود سوريا
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان اكد ان دمارا
كبيرا خلفه الزلزال اليوم في عدد من
المناطق مشيرا الى ان الاولويه الان هي
اعمال الانقاذ حيث يوجد 9000 عنصر ضمن ضمن
فرق الانقاذ
تسبب في هدم واضرار في عدد من المحافظات
وسبب دمارا كبيرا المحافظات استنفرت كل
قوتها الى جانب المحافظات ادارات الولايات
لهذه المحافظات ومؤسساتنا التي تعنى
بالكوارث القوات المسلحه التركيه ايضا تم
توظيفها في تلك المناطق اولويتنا كانت ولا
زالت هي اعمال الانقاذ حاليا يوجد 9000
عنصر ضمن فرق الانقاذ وسيتزايد هذا العدد
اردوغان اعلن في مؤتمر صحفي ان ارتفاع
اعداد ضحايا الزلزال او ارتفع الى 912
قتيلا واكد من واكثر من 5000 جريح وفيما
يتعلق بالمساعدات اكد اردوغان ان 45 دوله
الى جانب النيتو والاتحاد الاوروبي تشارك
في اعمال الانقاذ لمواجهه اثار الزلزال في
تركيا
حاليا هناك 912 مواطن توفي وما زاد على
خمسه الاف جريح
2,800 مبنى وهدمت بالكامل العديد من
المباني تضررت لا زالت عمليات الانقاذ
مستمره لا ندري الى اي مدى ستصل هذه
الارقام وبشان المساعدات الدوليه نتواصل
مع الدول الاخرى الى جانب الناتو والاتحاد
الاوروبي هناك 45 دوله قدمت طلبا لتساعدات
هذه الكارثه
من القاهره ينضم الينا مدير المرصد السوري
لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن سيد رامي
يعني ما اخطر ما يواجهون او كيف سيواجهون
السكان في سوريا خطر وتداعيات هذا الزلزال
وخطر ايضا الاجواء القارصه والعواصف
الثلجيه
نعم طبعا دعينا نبدا بالحصيله حقيقه الامر
وعلى اننا نتحدث بكل
ارتفاع العدد بالعشرات حتى اللحظه المؤكد
هو اكثر من 760 على الاقل 762 في مناطق
النظام مناطق
المعارضه ان الوضع كارثي وكارثي بامتياز
وحتى اللحظه التحديث هذا الجديد في مناطق
سيطره النظام يرتفع
يعني حسب المعطيات حسب المعلومات ان العدد
قد يصل الى 1000 وما يزيد الخسائر البشريه
كيف يواجهون شاهدنا المواجهه بمزيد من
الخسائر البشريه شاهدنا المواجهه بمزيد من
التشرد في الشوارع خوفا من هزات ارتداديه
بعد الهزه الاستداديه التي كانت بعض الصور
اليوم اي ان يعني المواطن السوري الان في
تلك المناطق لا يعلم اين يذهب هل سيذهب
الى داخل بعض المباني ان يبقى في الشارع
تحت الامطار في ظل الظروف الجويه القافيه
وايضا من هم تحت الانقاذ الان يعني هل هم
سيبكون تحت الانقاذ الى ان يتمكن احد من
انقاذهم ام هؤلاء سيكون مصيرهم بالموت دون
ان يتمكن اي شخص من انقاذهم واخراجهم من
تحت انقاذ هذه المباني المهدمه بالفعل
الوضع كارثي وايضا الوضع بالمراكز الطبيه
هل المراكز الطبيه هي قادره واين
الاسعافات التي تحدث عنها النظام التي
وصلت الى مدينه حلب لماذا لم تتمكن من
انقاذ ارواح الذين كانوا في المشافي اذا
ما كان هناك الطبيه بالفعل وصلت الى مدينه
حلب لا اعلم ماذا اقول ولكن ما اقوله بانه
رغم الوضع الكارسي حتى اللحظه الاغاثه لم
تصل الى هذه المناطق الميكروه
حتى الان ولكن ماذا عن المساعدات الدوليه
سيد رامي يعني الجانب الروسي تحدث عن
رغبته في ارسال مساعدات الى سوريا راينا
تصريحات ايضا من الصين راينا تصريحات من
مسؤول اسرائيلي بان هناك مساعده
للسوريين جاءت من داخل سوريا وطلبات من
داخل سوريا من غير الخوض في تفاصيل بحسب
تعبيره اين هذه المساعدات حتى الان تماما
ايضا المساعدات يعني المساعدات نحن نريد
ان نرى شيء على في الواقع لا نريد ان نسمع
كلام نريد ان نرى افعاله على ارض الواقع
هل وصلت المساعدات وهل يحتاج الامر الا
اننا سنرسل لا يوجد في داخل الاراضي
السوريه لروسيا على سبيل المثال يعني فرق
كوارث لهذا الامر هي قادر على الانقاذ
هناك على الانقاذ هناك ايران التي كانت
تدعي بانها تساعد نظام بشار الاسد
والسوريين لماذا لم ترسل الفرق انقاذ
مستعجله الى سوريا بشكل عاجل لمساعده يا
سيده مناطق النظام لماذا لم يدخل الى
مناطق سيطره المعارضه فرق انقاذ باغاثه
هؤلاء السوريين عندما يعني تنظرين شخص
موجود وانت ترينه تحت انقاذ المباني ولا
تستطيعنا انقاظه بسبب يعني قله الامكانيات
لدى فرق السوريه في تلك المناطق هذا شيء
كان الشخص وهو يفارق الحياه وانت عاجزه
على ان تنتشري هذا الطفل او هذا الشخص
شاهدنا شريف مصور طفل كان يعني عالق تحت
الارض لم يتمكن احد في كان موجود يطلب منه
ان يعني يردد الشهاده لانه يعلم بانه
سيفارق الحياه وبالفعل هو فارق الحياه هذه
الحالات هي كثيره وكثيره جدا والمخاوف
الاكثر بان يكون هناك همسات ارتداديه
جديده وان تنهار المزيد من المباني في هذه
المناطق السوريه التي تعرضت لكارثه كبيره
واقول لك بصراحه النظام لا يقف على حجم
الكارثه ويتحدث عنه بانها امل عادي بينما
هي كارثه اكبر بكثير بالامكانيات النظام
السوري طيب السيد رامي ما الطرق لتوصيل
المساعدات الخاء القادمه من خارج سوريا
يعني هلا عبر تركيا هو الطريق الانسب ام
هناك طرق اخرى يمكن ان تصل المساعدات
الدوليه بشكل اسرع الى سوريا
من ترسل الطائرات التي تريد ان تساعد بشكل
عاجل بمطار حلب وان تفتح المعابر ما بين
سيطره النظام وسيطره المعارضه وسيطره
العياء الان الموضوع انساني لا يتعلق
بقضيه راسيه وقضيه معارضه ونظام القضيه
بان هناك ابناء الشعب السوري يموتون في كل
دقيقه تحدثنا منذ نصف ساعه كان العدد 720
الان نتحدث عن الارقام ترتفع بالعشرات بكل
لحظه لذلك الامر يعني لا يحتاج الى كثير
من الانتفار يحتاج الى افتتاح مطار حلب
ليس من اجل نقل الذخيره الايرانيه من اجل
نقل المواز لاغاثه اقل من الفرق الالقاب
لهذه المنطقه لاضافه السوريين ما بين
مناطق المعارضه ومناطق طيب شكرا لك من
القاهره مرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي
عبد الرحمن مشاهدينا الى نتابع هذه الصور
امامنا لفرق الانقاذ
يقومون بازاله الانقاض ومحاوله البحث عن
احياء تحت العنقاض للمصابين اثرى تداعيات
هذا الزلزال اذا يبدو ان هذه الصور التي
نراها امامنا الان هي الصور المباشره
وهناك عاجل من وكاله الكوارث التركيه يقول
بان ارتفاع عدد قتل الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب
البلاد وصل الى اكثر من الف قتيل اذا 14
قتيلا حتى الان وبحسب وكاله الكوارث
التركيه عدد قتلى الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب
تركيا هذه صور مباشره ننقلها لكم مشاهدينا
نذهب الى اسطنبول الان ومعنا مراسل
العربيه زيدان زنكلو زيدان يعني
ارتفاع يعني كبير في عدد ضحايا الزلزال
حتى الان ماذا لديك من معلومات جديده حول
تداعيات هذه الكارثه
نعم قبل قليل اعلنت هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه افاد وارتفاع عدد الضحايا الى 10
شخصا في الولايات العشره التي ضربها
الزلزال ايضا
ذكرت انه بعد الزلزال الثاني الذي
ضرب ولايه كهرمان مرعش في تمام الساعه
الواحده والربع تقريبا قبل حوالي ساعتين
من الان لم يعد هناك خطر من حدوث تسونامي
يمكن ان يضرب سواحل شرق البحر المتوسط او
المدن الواقعه المدن التركيه في شرق البحر
المتوسط اذا خطر تسونامي لم يعد موجودا
بحسب افاد طبعا السلطات التركيه تحاول
ارسال المزيد من فرق الانقاذ الى الولايات
المنكوبه الجيش التركي فتح جسر جويا
للولايات العشر طرق الانقاذ تحاول الوصول
الى تلك المناطق لكن مع مع كل هذه الجهود
هناك دائما عقارات المشكله الاولى هي
الحاله الجويه السيئه التي تعيق وصول بعض
او طلاق الفرق الانقاذ التي كانت تريد
الذهاب عبر البر او من طرق البريه باتجاه
المدن الجنوبيه بحسب ما رايناه من نشره
الطرق ان مع الطرق التي تصل الى منطقه
غازي عنتاب وهو الطريق الدولي القادم من
انقره مرورا باضنه ومن ثم
عثمانيه والى
كهرمان مرعش وغازي عنتاب هذا الطريق حتى
الان مغلق بحسب نشره الطرق التي وصلتنا
قبل قليل
وبالتالي الخيار الوحيد هو المجال الجوي
او الجسر الجوي لكن بعض المطارات اغلقت
بسبب الزلزال الثاني اخر مطار كان مطار
اضنه التي اعلنت قبل قليل اداره او
السلطان في اغلاق هذا المسار طبعا هناك
تخوف كبير من هزات ارتداديه اخرى الاعزاء
الاعتداديه لم تتوقف حقيقه منذ الصباح
وحتى هذا اليوم وحتى هذه الساعه عفوا
اعتداديه بشكل كبير جدا في معظم المناطق
اكثر المناطق التي من المتوقع ان يكون
فيها اضرار هي ولايه كهرمان مرعش التي
ضربها
الاول في فجر هذا اليوم كان بقوه 7.7
والاخر ايضا بقوه كانت شدته 7.6 درجات على
مقياس ريختر نفسه الولايه ضربها
الزلزالين لذلك التوقعات كبيره بان تكون
هناك
خسائر كبيره كانت ماديه او بشريه ما لم
يتم ايصال
المساعدات او حتى
لحين وصول المساعدات زيدان ابقى معنا
كرمان سانتقل الى القامشلي ومراسلنا
مراسلنا هناك جمعه عكاش جمعه يعني ارتفاع
مهول في عدد القتلى جراء هذا الزلزال ان
كان في الداخل التركي او حتى في الداخل
السوري كيف تجري عمليات الانقاذ هل من
مساعدات وصلت الى حيث الى القامشلي او الى
المناطق المتضرره حولكم حتى الان يعني
فعلا الاعداد ارتفعت منذ ساعات الصباح
الاولى وحتى الان
يعني كنا نتحدث عن فجاه تحدثنا عن 200
الان نحن نتحدث عن احصائيتين الاولى تقول
بان هناك بيئتين 2021 قتيلا في مناطق
المعارضه
337 في مناطق النظام اي نحن نتحدث عن
قرابه 600 لقد شخص فقدوا حياتهم في هذا
الزلزال بينما الاحصائيه الاخرى تتحدث عن
اكثر من 720 شخص فقدوا حياتهم في هذا
الزلزال نحن نتحدث عن كارثه ان كامله
الاوصاف اذا نظرنا الى الى الارض حيث
الفرق فرق لانقاذ تفشل او يمكن ان نسمي ما
تقوم به فشل في في ازاله الانقاض ويعني
انقاذ ما يمكن انقاذهم من
البشر الموجودين والعالقين تحت انقاذ هذه
المنازل هم يعملون كل ما يمكن ان يستعمله
الفرق المحدوده الامكانيات نتيجه
لضعف امكانياتها الماديه وضعف امكانياتها
البشريه هؤلاء يعني يحاولون انتشال
الضحايا من مساحات جغرافيه واسعه ومن
احيان تدمرت
بالكامل ومن منازل يعني بالعشرات باستخدام
الات بسيطه ومعدات يعني لا تلتقي الى
مستوى هذه
الكارثه اما اذا كنت تسالينني عن
المساعدات حتى هذه اللحظه لا مناطق النظام
ولا مناطق المعارضه دخلت
في الميدان تقوم يعني فرق الدفاع المدني
بازاله الانقاذ عبر الرافعات يعني اليات
اليات التريكس وغيرها
وايضا باستخدام يعني يعني الايادي خاصه
وان فريق من المتطوعين المحليين وقفوا الى
جانب الدفاع يعني الدفاع المدني لازاله
هذه الانقاض وركامل بيوت ومخالفات
الدمار كان هناك انتشار لحوالي 50 شخص
احياء اصاباتهم وجروحهم مختلفه ومتفاوته
تم اسعاف اغلبهم الى البشره الرئيسي في
مدينه ادلب اضافه الى المشفى العسكري في
مدينه عفرين ايضا تم يعني ازاله ثلاثه او
اربعه جثث منذ يعني خمس ساعات وحتى الان
من تحت الانقاض هؤلاء المصابين الذين يتم
انقاذ حياتهم يتوجهون الى المشافي ولا
يجدون اماكن لي او اسره لتلاقي العلاج او
اجراء العمليات لان غرف المشدده منتظمه
يعني
كامله ولا يمكنها استقبال المزيد من
المرضى حتى المستشفيات يعني كانت توصلنا
صور خاصه بالمشفى من مشفى عفرين العسكري
بان الجرحى والمصابين ينامون على ارصفه
على ارصفه المستشفى
ان المستشفيات بدات تقتضي وبدات تصل الى
طاقتها القصوى ولكن اسمح لي ابقى معي
واسمح لي ان اذهب الى زيدان واعود اليه
ويعني زيدان في تركيا الوضع ربما وضع
المستشفيات وضع الامكانات الطبيه افضل
بقليل مما هو عليه في سوريا ما الامكانات
المتوفره والتي يستخدمونها في تركيا
لمساعدات المتضررين
نعم بدايه لا شك ان الاعداد الكبيره
للجرحى او حتى للضحايا تزيد العبء على
الطواقم الطبيه نتحدث عن اكثر من 5000
مصاب حتى الان من ضمن المناطق التي وصلها
او حتى الان هناك تحديث ان العدد المصابين
ارتفع الى 7000 اكثر من 7000 مصابه الان
تحديث مباشر نسمعه
هم ضحايا الزلزال حتى الان الزلازل حتى
الان واكثر من 7000 جريح هم عدد الجرحى
والمصابين الزلازل وبالتالي الحصيله مرشحه
للارتفاع اليوم مع هذا العدد الكبير ورغم
وجود مشاكل ضخمه في الولايات العشره
الجنوبيه لكن عدد الجراحه كبير لذلك قاطعه
الاصابات الخفيفه يتم علاجها فورا ومن ثم
اخراج اخراجهم بعد التاكد من سلامتهم من
المشفى واستقبال حالات جديده الحالات
المتوسطه او الحالات الحرجه تبقى في
المشتاق الان بانتظار ان تفتح الطرق او ان
يكون هناك مجال لنقل الحالات بعض في حال
اصبح ضغط
من ذلك على المشافي
تضطر السلطات والتواقم الطبيه الى نقل
المصابين الى مشاكل خارج هذه المناطق
المنكوبه طبعا حتى الان هذا الموضوع على
ما يبدو انه صعب نتيجه
الظروف الجويه واغلاق الطرق وايضا اغلاق
الطرق سواء بسبب الزلازل او حتى بسبب
الظروف الجويه الحاليه
وبالتالي هذا سيزيد من الضغط ربما على
التواقض الطبيه
ما هي المطارات المفتوحه لاستقبال
المساعدات وما هي المطارات المغلقه حتى
الان
حتى الان المطارات المغلقه بشكل كامل من
الاكيد ان مطار اضنه هو اخر المطارات
المغلقه حسب ما علمنا ايضا مطار كهرمان
مرعش مغلق امام
الحركه الجويه وربما ايضا مطار كان حديث
من نائب الرئيس التركي قبل ساعتين او ثلاث
ساعات عن ان مطار هاتاي نتيجه الضرر الذي
حصل بجوار هذا المطار هناك
توقف العمل في مطار لكن بقيه المطارات
يعني كان مطار غازي عنتاب او مسار اورفا
هم فقط هما المطران اللذان يستقبلان
المساعدات او الطواقم الانقاذ التي تصل
تباعا عبر جسر جوي ارسلته او انشاته وزاره
الدفاع التركيه لاغاثه المناطق المنكوبه
هي هذه حتى الان لا توجد معلومات اكيده عن
عدد المطارات لكن من المؤكد ان هذين
المصارين ربما هم الاكثر ترجيح هم
هذان هو وما الذين
يستقبلان الطواقم او الكوادر الطبيه وفرق
الانقاذ التي تاتي من سائر الولايات
التركيه الى هذه الى المناطق المنسوبه طيب
زيدان ابقى معي واذكر بما يحدث الان في
تركيا وسوريا يعني هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا والذي يعد الاكبر والاكثر ضررا منذ
العام
1939 وثاني اكبر زلزال ضرب البلاد
وتداعياتهم امتدت الى الشمال السوري والذي
ادى الى وفاه حتى الان اكثر من 700 قتيل
جراء هذا الزلزال في سوريا واكثر من 900
والان اصبح
الفتيل في تركيا اثر هذا الزلزال وطبعا
المختصون في الجيولوجيا والخبراء ذكروا
بان عمق الزلزال وقوه الزلزال تلعب دورا
مهما في اثره في امتداده وفي تداعياته وفي
ايضا الهزات الارتداديه التي يمكن ان
تشهدها المناطق المتضرره هذا الزلزال
تحديدا الذي ضرب تركيا فجر هذا اليوم كان
بقوه
7.8 درجه على مقياس وكان بعمق
17.9 كيلو متر ويعني من المتوقع ان تستمر
الهزات الارتداديه لعده اشهر بحسب خبراء
الجيولوجيا ولكن مع التضاع مع ضعف تاثيره
وقوته على المباني وعلى الارض وعلى ايضا
البشر اذا يعني ربما تداعيات هذه تستمر
لعده اسابيع ربما لعده اشهر ولكن بشكل اخف
واخف واخف اعود الى القامشلي ومراسل
العربيه جمعه عكاش الجمعه كيف يتعاون
المدنيون يعني مع اكتظاظ المستشفيات ومع
قله الامكانات المدنيون هم يعني يتكتفون
هم الامل الوحيد لبعضهم البعض فكيف
يتصرفون يتعاملون مع هذه الازمات يعني
القادرون من المدنيين يعني ينشقوا الى
فريقين الفريق الاول يساعد الفوز البيضاء
في ازاله الانقاض والركاب من المباني
والبحث عن الضحايا سواء كانوا قد فارقوا
الحياه او على قيد الحياه البعض الجمعه
الامم المتحده تتوقع مزيدا من الضحايا في
سوريا جراء الزلزال بحسب هذا العاجل الذي
يريدنا تفضل جمعه بالضبط يعني لا يزال
العشرات من الاسر خاصه في منطقه الاتارب
وايضا في بلده جنديرس تحت
الانقاض وهو ما يرشح عدد الضحايا للنحوة
الارتفاع اما الفريق الثاني من المدنيين
يساعدون الطواقم الطبيه في عمليات الاخلاء
وايضا في عمليات الاسعاف الى المشافي وبعض
ممن يمتلكون القدرات الطبيه او يلمون
بامور التمريض والطبيابه ذهبوا الى
المشافي
ويساعدون الاطباء والطاقم الطبي في مداوات
جراح
الضحايا بعضهم ايضا من الاطباء الذين
يمتلكون العيادات الخاصه خاصه في منطقه
عفرين فتحوا عياداتهم لاستقبال الحالات
الطفيفه
المتوسطه لمعالجهم في عياداتهم الخاصه
مجانا دون يعني يعني الحصول على اجر مادي
مقابل خدم خدماتهم الاطباء الذين يفهمون
بالجراحه العصبيه توجهوا الى مستشفى عفرين
الذي يستقبل حالات اصابه ومعقده خاصه
حالات الكسور في الجمجمه والكسور في يعني
في في عظام
الجسم بسبب ضعف الامكانيات هناك تكاتف
كبير من المدنيين مع مع ضحايا هذا الزلزال
الاسيوي ان الكثيرين منهم يقومون بايواء
سكان السكان الذين تدمرت منازلهم او تعرضت
تدمير الجزئي يقومون باوائهم في
منازلهم بسبب ظروف الطقس
القاسيه هناك امطار وبعض المناطق حصلت
عليها الثلوج والحراره تصل الى ادنى من
درجه صفر مئويه في كثير من مناطق شمال غرب
سوريا لذلك في ظل نقص الامكانيات
الخارجيه او غياب تام للمساعدات الخارجيه
حتى هذه اللحظه يكون الدور الاكبر مناض
باهالي وسكان بلدات ومدن شمال غرب سوريا
للتعامل مع هذه الكارثه والتخفيف من
تداعياتها طيب يبدو اننا ونحن نتحدث جمعا
نشاهد صور لشخص تم انقاذه من تحت الانقاض
قبل قليل شخص او شخصين يبدو انهم شخصان
وهم كبار في العمر حقيقه كما يبدو
وهمم يعني في حاله الذعر في حاله
يبدو انهم يعني سعيدين طبعا ولكنهم ايضا
عورون ولا يصدقون بانهم خرجوا من تحت
الانقاذ هناك يعني الناس من حولهم يتطمنون
عليهم لنستمع قليلا
اذا شاهدنا قبل قليل الصور لشخص او اثنان
تم انقاذهم من تحت الانقاذ وهم كبار في
السن الى يعني نسبيا وهم في حاله ذعر وفي
حاله يعني امتنان لخروجهم من تحت الانقاذ
اعود الى
او انتقل الى احمد مظهر سعدو صحفي من غازي
عنتاب سيد احمد يعني ما زالت عمليات
الانقاذ قائمه وما زال هناك احياء تحت
الانقاض كيف تجري هذه العمليات حتى الان
كل التحيه لكم وللمشاهدين جميعا هو لا شك
انه عمليه الانقاذ مستمره
ومتواصله لان حجم الكارثه الكبير وكبير
جدا وفي كثير من الولايات حتى الان لا
يستطيع
مسؤول الانقاذ وعامله الانقاذ الوصول الى
الناس لكثره يؤني المتهدم وخاصه مثلا في
منطقه في انتاج فلذلك باعتقادي انه
المساله ستطول وتطول اكثر وخاصه انه الهزه
الارتزاديه التي حصلت منذ ساعه ونصف
تقريبا هي ايضا خطيره كانت بقوه الهزه
الصباحيه الاساسيه او اقل منها بقليل لكن
لم تطل طويلا لكن حقيقه هي هزه قويه ايضا
وهذه تؤدي الى تصدعات جديده لانه في الهزه
الاولى البناء الذي لم
ادى الى تصدر وتشقق فيه وبالتالي الهجره
والقويه خاصه منها يمكن ان تؤدي الى
انهيارات جديده وخاصه ان هناك الناس لا
زالوا حتى الان يتحدثون عن
احتمالات كبيره لارتدادات ايضا قادمه
الساعه اربعه مثلا قيل وايضا قيل ليلا
يعني يبدو لم تنتهي بعد ارضيه جديده سيد
احمد تقصد ام ارتداديه
لكن الهزه التي حصلت قبل ساعه ساعه ونصف
بعض المحللين العلميين المختصين بالزلازل
قالوا انها هي هزه جديده وليست ارتداد
اقوى من سبعه درجات على فهي جديده بحسب
الخبراء وان كانت اقل فهي ارتداديه
صحيح هي حصلت سبعه ونصف كانت الهزه
الاخيره اللي حصلت قبل ساعه ونصف لذلك هي
يقال ان هزه جديده وهنا اقول انه الهزات
الارتداديه يعني يمكن ان تكون ايضا تؤدي
لانهيارات وهي خطيره جدا لانه الابن في
محرمها الابن تشققت يعني الهزات الطويله
والقويه التي وصلت
7.8.9 ادت الى تشقق الامني حتى الابن
الحديثه يعني ناهيك على الابن القديم التي
ادى الى انهيارات في جدرانها كليه وحتى
اللحظه هناك عمل جاد من اجل انقاذ الناس
تحت الانقاذ وهناك مثلا قيل لي قبل قليل
في مرعش ام واطفالها ما زالوا حتى الانقاذ
لا عنهم شيء هل هم احياء واموات ولا
يستطيعون لان اجزاء كبيره جدا والامكانيات
متواضعه ايضا صحيح ان هناك شغل جدي من
خلال الافاد والمنظمات المس عن الانقاذ
لكن حقيقه العمل كبير جدا ولم يتوقعه احد
ان يكون بهذا الاتساع مع الولايات في
تركيا واكثر من 200 قريه في شمال سوريا
يعني مساحه هذا الارضيه كانت كبيره وكبيره
جدا لم تكن مركزه فقط في مكان محدد بعينه
كما يحصل في مرات سابقه
طيب شكرا لك سيد احمد ابقى معنا اعود الى
مراسلنا زيدان زيدان يعني ضعنا في الصوره
لما هو جديد لديك حول هذه الكوارث
والاصابات والضحايا اثر هذا الزلزال
نعم اعيد بتذكير بالحصيله النهائيه التي
اعلنت عنها اثار هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه وهي 14 شخصا لقوا مصنعهم نتيجه
البلابل المتكرره الزلزالين الرئيسيين
وهناك اكثر من 7000 جريح حتى الان واكثر
من
2800 مبنى دمر نتيجه هذين الزلزلين اللذين
وقع في نفس المنطقه في ولايه كهرمان مرعش
وكان لهم اثار سلبيه على الولايات
المجاوره ونتحدث هنا عن 10 ولايات طبعا ما
عدا عشرات الهزات الارتداديه التي ضربت
هذه الولايات منذ ساعات الصباح
وحتى هذه اللحظه وهذا ما يزيد من المعاناه
ايذاء هذه التطورات طبعا المدارس في اربع
ولايات من المناطق او الولايات الاكثر
تضررا
التمديد التعليق الدوام في المدارس
والجامعات لمده اسبوع اخر لان المدارس
والجامعات فتتوقف لمده اسبوعين في
الولايات الاربعه ومنها على سبيل المثال
ملاطيا وكهرباء المرعش واظيما بينما
الولايات السته المتبقيه حتى الان نتحدث
حتى الان قررت ان تعلق المدارس والجامعات
لمده اسبوع واحد فقط وبعض وبعد مرور
الاسبوع سيتم تقييم الوضع ربما تمديد هذا
التعليق او استكمال او استئناف النشاط
الدراسي او نشاط المدارس والجامعات ايضا
في سبيل موضوع توفير الماوى
المرافق الرياضيه او النشاطات الرياضيه
توقفت بشكل كامل في البلاد لحتى وضعت كل
المرافق الرياضيه والصلاه الرياضيه في
خدمه اطقم الانقاذ
لوكبر عدد من
[موسيقى]
السكان الذين تضررت منازلهم ولا يستطيعون
العوده اليها اما دمار بشكل كامل او دمار
بشكل جزئي او حتى تصدعات وتشققات هذا
الموضوع خطر جدا وتحذر منه السلطات تركيا
وتنبه على المواطنين الذين
لديهم منازل فيها بعض
تشققات بضروره عدم الدخول اليها مهما كان
الظرف لان الهزات الارتداديه كما قال نائب
رئيس التركي
ظهر هذا اليوم الهزات الاعتداريه اليوم هي
اخطر من الزلزال بحد ذاته لان هذه الهزات
قد تؤدي الى انهيار الكثير من المباني
التي تصدعت نتيجه الزلزاله الاول وما زاد
كما كما تحدثنا قبل قليل ما زاد من
المعاناه ان الزلزال الثاني ايضا جاء في
ولايه كهرمان مرعش وجاء بتقريبا او على
وجه التحديد 7.6 درجات على مقياس ما اكلته
وافاد هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه طبعا
الهلال الاحمر التركي
كل مراكزه لاستقبال المرضى وايضا وجه
نداءات للمواطنين للتبرع بالدم تحسبا لاي
نقص قد يحصل في امدادات الدم لدى المصابين
او الجرحى وبالتالي
نتحدث الان جاء خبر عاجل قبل قليل ان مسار
انقره فتح لكن ليس امام حركه المسافرين
انما امام طواقم الانقاذ طبعا
عفوا مطار اضنه هو الذي فتح امام حركه
لابد ان العوائل واعداد الذين خرجوا من
منازلهم اثرى انهيار هذه المنازل يعني
2824 مبنى تم تدميره من قبل هذا الزلزال
الزيدان يعني هذه الاعداد من الناس الذين
اصبحوا باتوا من غير منازل ومن غير ماوى
ولجاوا الى الصلاه الرياضيه الى المدارس
الى المطارات المغلقه ربما يعني هناك
صعوبه في ان تصل لهم الامدادات الطبيه
ولكن ماذا عن الغذاء والماء
والمؤونه هل تصلهم
[موسيقى]
بهذا الموضوع نعم بعض المراكز تصلهم لكن
كما ذكرت الاعداد كبيره نتحدث عن عشر
ولايات واليوم الحديث عن 2800 مبنى دمر
فقط يعني هذا الذي وصلته فرق الانقاذ
واستطاعت احصاء هذا هذا العدد من المباني
من المتوقع ان يكون العدد اكبر من ذلك
اكثر من ذلك بكثير نتيجه الزلزال الثاني
الذي حصل قبل ساعتين في كهرمان مرعش
وبالتالي يعني نتحدث عن اعداد مباني ربما
دررت بشكل اكبر اكبر من الرقم المعلن حتى
الان
وربما اعداد اكثر بحاجه الى ماوى وايضا
بحاجه الى مساعده ولذلك تركيا منذ ساعات
الصباح
وجهت يعني او اعلنت حاله الانذار من
المستوى الرابع
لتلقي الدعم والمساعده وكانت التركيز على
طواقب على القارب اليوم بحاجه الى طواقم
قال للوصول الى عدد اكبر من المواقع التي
شهدت
دمارا وبالتالي امكانيه انقاذ العالقين
هناك بشكل اسرع واعطاء امل للموجودين تحت
الانقاض في حال وسع توقم الانقاذ لهم طيب
ابقى معنا زيدان ننتقل الى القامشلي
ومراسلنا جمعه ولكن اشير الى هذا العاجل
من المستشار الالماني
لاردوغان نحن مستعدون لتقديم الدعم بعد
الزلزال اذا المستشار الالماني
بانه على استعداد بان تقدم المانيا الدعم
لتركيا بعد الزلزال يعني جمعه الاعداد
المباني زادت عن 2800 التي دمرت في تركيا
كيف هي واوضاع المباني في سوريا وهي التي
مهترئه بالفعل من قبل الزلزال
يعني دعيني احدث لك الان الحصيله النهائيه
كما وردتني من المصادر في مناطق المعارضه
وايضا في مناطق النظام مناطق المعارضه
حدثت يعني اعداد القتل من 221 قتيل الى
400 قتيل وفق مصدر مسؤول في الدفاع المدني
هيئه الصحه التابعه للنظام السوري حدثت
الارقام من 337 قتيل الى 404 قتلى اي نحن
نتحدث الان عن حصيله اجماليه غير نهائيه
لاعداد الضحايا عددهم بلغ الان من 720
اصبح العدد الان
804 اشخاص فقدوا حياتهم في في هذا الزلزال
وهذه الحصيله وفق المصدرين حصيله غير
اما عند وضع المباني طبعا هذه المنطقه
منطقه شمال غرب سوريا شهدت حربا منذ حوالي
عشره
عاما اثرت هذه الحرب والاعمال القتاليه
على مجمل
المباني والدور السكنيه والعمارات في هذه
المنطقه
عندما نزح اليها السوريون من ارياف دمشق
وحمص وحلب بعضهم سكنوا في بيوت فقدت
قيمتها الزمنيه واخرين سكنوا في بيوت غير
مكتمله وهذا ما يفسر يعني العدد الكبير من
المنازل التي تدمرت بالكامل احياء تدمرت
بالكامل خاصه في سرمدا بريف ادبل الشمالي
وايضا في منطقه جنديرس قرب مدينه
عفرين بسبب الارتدادات وعددها حوالي 48
ارتداد شعر به سكان شمال غرب وشمال شرق
سوريا يرى شمال غرب سوريا جمعه رئيس
اليونان يقول بانه يتعهد بتقديم كل
المساعدات الممكنه لتركيا في اعقاب
الزلزال ابقى معي جمعه كرما انتقل الى سيد
احمد مظهر صحفي من غازي عنتاب اهلا بك
معنا مجددا السيد احمد ايضا الفرق الانقاذ
ما زالت تعمل المساعدات ما زالت مرتقبه
ومنتظره الناس يؤوون الى الملاجئ والى
صلاه الرياضه وغيره من المناطق التي اخلت
لاستقبال المتضررين انقل لنا الجديد لديك
حول هذا الحادث
نعم نعم ما زالت سيارات اسعاف نسمع
صافرتها بين الفينه والاخرى وهي تنقل من
هو يمكن انقاذه من تحت الانقاذ الى
المشافي والمستوصفات والامارات الصحيه
وهذا يؤكد على ان المساله هي طويله ولن
تنتهي منذ ساعات الصباح الاولى وحتى الان
ما زال هناك الكثير تحت الانقاض وما زال
هناك جهد يبذل لدى الافاد وكل المسؤولين
عن حاله الانقاذ الاتراك وايضا امن ياتي
ليساعده من الخارج كل ذلك يبدل بجهود
كبيره وحشيشه
ومستمره من اجل انقاذ ارواح الناس او
الاصالهم الى اقرب مكان للايجار يعني هناك
الكثير ممن يعني يخرجون من تحت الانقاض
احب من تهدم بيته يبحث عن مكانه وخاصه في
ظل هذا الطقس البارد جدا الثلوج التي تهطل
في عنتاب حاليا فهذا يشير الى ان الوضع
صعب للغايه سواء كان من تضرر او من تضرر
بيته او جسمه او شر ذلك كل ذلك يؤدي الى
حالات صعبه تحتاج الى ان يكون هناك فزعه
كما يقال ليس فقط على مستوى التركي بل على
مستوى العربي والدولي
لانقاذ هؤلاء العرب والمسلمين من السوريين
والاستاد ايضا في هذه المنطقه الذين
يعانون ما يعانون من حالات
السيد احمد بالنسبه للمخاوف من الهزات
الارتداديه وهزات والزلازل الجديده كما
ذكرت الانباء وكما ذكر احد ضيوفنا ايضا
بان هناك هزات جديده مرتقبه وقادمه في
منتصف الليل
اين تلجاون لجمع هذه المعلومات يعني هل
تعتمدون على المعاهد الامريكي للمسح
الجيولوجي ام هناك جهات اخرى يرصدون
يراقبون وضع الزلازل والهزات الارتداديه
يعني هناك طبعا يعني من يتابع يتابع في
هناك مراكز الابحاث
[موسيقى]
اليوم في غزه ارتداديه طبعا نامل ان لتكون
كبيره كسابقتها لكن اعتقادي ان كل ذلك
يؤكد على ان المساله لم تنتهي
بعد فان
[موسيقى]
الناس وعلى ان الخوف والذعر الموجود في
عيون الناس الذين نراهم كل يوم هو يؤكد
على ان القضيه فعلا يعني تحتاج الى المزيد
من العنايه وطبعا انا اتحدث معكم من
الشارع لانه لا يستطيع احد حل العوده الى
منزله لان الوضع صعب وخطر للغايه طيب
نتمنى لكم السلامه سيد احمد ابقى معنا
واعود الى القامشلي ومراسلنا هناك جمعه
عكاش جمعه كيف هي الاوضاع الان يعني هناك
ترقب لمزيد من الزلازل والمزيد من الهزات
الارتداديه ما الاستعدادات رغم ان الجميع
مشغولون الان بمساعده المصابين وازاله
الانقاض التي يعني تسبب بهذا الزلزال
الاول
نعم يعني ايه في هذه الاثناء بدات الاطراف
المختلفه نظام المعارضه والاكرار باتخاذ
اجراءات
وقائيه تدبيريه مثلا الاداره الذاتيه منذ
حوالي 6 دقائق اعلن تعطيل المدارس في جميع
المناطق الواقعه سيطرتها اعتبارا من اليوم
وحتى التاسع من الشهر الجاري على نفسه
وتيره اعلنت وزاره التربيه التابعه لنظام
ايضا تعطيل المدارس
تعطيل المدارس حتى نهايه هذا الاسبوع اي
المدرسه تبدا اعتبارا من يوم الاحد
المقبل الاداره الذاتيه ايضا لتعطيل
المؤسسات التابعه لها ايضا بشكل كامل حتى
يوم التاسع من الشهر
الجاري باستثناء المؤسسات والدوائر التي
يتوجب باستمرار العمل فيها نفس الخطوه
خططها مناطق
المعارضه كان هناك يعني منذ حوالي نصف
ارشادات من جميع الفرقاء في المشهد السوري
بالضروره اتخاذ التدابير والخروج من
المنازل فور الشعور باي اهزاء هزات جديده
والتوجه الى الساحات ويعني ترك المباني
المتصديه او التي حدث فيها شقوق نتيجه
الزلزالين والارتدادات الكثير التي نجم عن
الزلزالين طيب شكرا جمعه على هذه
المعلومات ابقى معي وسانتقل مجددا الى
احمد مظهر سعد من غازي عنتاب سيد احمد
يعني هل لك ان تجمل لنا ابرز التصريحات
التي خرجت من المسؤولين في تركيا ان كان
من الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ومن نائبه او
من اي مسؤولين اخرين خرجوا وصرحوا حول هذه
الكارثه
احنا طبعا ابرز ما قيل هو تصريحات وكلمه
رئيس اردوغان اخيرا حول موضوع الزلزال
الذي اكد فيها على ان كل تركيا بما تحويه
هي منشغله اليوم في موضوع الزلزال وقد
اجرت كثير من قضايا وصولا الى حل مشاكل
الناس في الوقوف الى جانبهم واكد على ان
انه يقبل بالمعونه من الدول الغربيه
وغيرها الكل يفترض ان يقدم ويساعد في هذا
الموضوع واشار الى انه اتخذ اجراءات رسميه
وقويه فيما يتعلق بارسال حتى مسؤولين كبار
بالدوله المناطق المنكوبه خاصه اربع
ولايات الخمس ولايات المنفوة اكثر نكبه من
اجل ان يقفوا على الوضع ويتابعوه بشكل جدي
وهم على صله مباشره بالرئاسه ورئيه
الجمهوريه طبعا اضافه الى ما قيل انه
ارسال هام جدا الى جلاله هو خلال وزير
الداخليه وايضا كان ولا زال يجول في كل
المناطق التي فيها وقعت فيها حوادث زلازل
وهذه مساله طبعا بالتاكيد تؤكد على اهتمام
هذه الدوله بذلك انا اعتقد انه هنا ايضا
موضوع التصريحات اليونانيه مهمه
جدا نحن نعرف ان هناك خلافات سياسيه كبيره
من اليونان وتركيا اليوم يبدو انه من اجل
الوضع الانساني
واحتباء احتمالا باتجاه تاكيد ان العلاقه
الانسانيه هي الاقوى فهناك تصريحات
وتاكيدات طبعا تركيا من جانب تلك ان يقبل
اي مساعده او باعوني او وقفه يونانيه حتى
لو كان هناك خلافات سياسيه واعتقد ان حتى
بعض الدول الاخرى قد اعلنت الوقوف الى
جانب تركيا في هذه الماسات وهذه
الكارثه الكبرى ومن ثم فان التصريحات حتى
الاوروبيين التي حصلت استقبلها المسؤولين
الاتراك في رحاب الصدر واكثروا على انه
على استعداد لاستقبال اي معونه او الوقوف
الى جانبهم من خلال هذه الكارثه
سيد احمد ابقى معي وانتقل الى مراسلنا
زيدان للحديث اكثر عن هذه المساعدات زيدان
هل لك ان تجمل لنا ابرز الدول التي تعهدت
بتقديم المساعدات الى تركيا وهل وصل اي
منها حتى الان
نعم
مساعدات التي ارسلتها او فرق الانقاذ
الذين ارسلتهم من المتوقع ان يكونوا اول
الواصلين الى
تركيا حتى الان لا لم تعلن السلطات وصول
فرق المساعدات من الرجال او من دول اخرى
لكن من ضمن الدول طبعا ذكرنا اذربيجان
ايضا ذكرنا
روسيا تعادت بارسال المساعدات وايضا بعض
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي اسرائيل ربما ترسل
مساعدات حتى الان يعني ننتظر التاكيدات
الرسميه من هنا من انقره ايضا كما ذكرت
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي وقت سابق اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ايضا ابدت
استعلام عن الارسال المساعدات لكن كما
ذكرت يعني اليوم
وصول المساعدات تركيا فعلا هي بحاجه لهذه
المساعدات نتحدث تحديدا او حددت تركيا
طلباتها او المساعدات التي تريدها تريدها
بشكل عاجل وبشكل ملح وهي فرق وايضا
المساعدات الطبيه حجم الدمار على ما يبدو
انه كبير جدا ويبدو ان الامور تتكشف شيئا
فشيئا مع وصول فرق انقاذ جديده يبدو ان
هناك مناطق اخرى لم ترسلها من قبل فرق
الانقاذ لذلك تحاول او تريد السلطات
التركيه سواء من خلال طواقم الانقاذ التي
تتحرك من كل الولايات التركيه الى المناطق
العشره المنكوبه او الولايات العشر
المنكوبه او من خلال المساعدات الخارجيه
تريد زياده عدد طواقم فرق الانقاذ للوصول
الى اكبر عدد من العالقين تحت المباني او
اسفل المباني وتحت الانقاض في محاوله ربما
لانقاذ حياتها اولى واعطاء امل لحياه
جديده لهؤلاء وعدم تكبد خسائر اضافيه في
الارواح يعني هم الحكومه التركيه في سباق
مع الزمن الجيش التركي فتح
جسترن جويا باتجاه المناطق المنسوبه
المناطق العاشره
ايضا
ايضا كل مؤسسات الدوله وهيئه الكوارث
والطوارئ تحاول المساعده في هذا الموضوع
حتى ان المطارات الموجوده في المدن العشره
التي تعمل التي مازال تعمل خصصت فقط
لطواقم الانقاذ وتوقفت بها كل الرحلات
المدنيه كل الرحلات المسافرين توقفت بشكل
كامل فقط
لافساح المجال لطواقم الانقاذ للوصول الى
هناك الخوف كل الخوف من حتى الان من
السلطات التركيه من الهزاز الارتداديه
والنشاط الزلزالي الذي الذي يظهر على شكل
هزاز ارتداديه تخش السلطات التركيه من ان
هذه الهزات الاعتياديه ربما ستزيد من
المطاعم في حال ان هناك مباني او هناك
مباني كثيره تشققت او تصدعت هذه الهزات
التي تخشى السلطات التركيه ان تؤدي الى
انهيار هذه المباني او جزء من هذه المباني
ولذلك يعني
درجه وقدر عمقه ب
18.30 كيلو متر تحت الارض بخط عرض بلغ
سبعه وثلاثين فاصله ثلاثه عشر شمالا وخط
الطول مشاهدينا بلغ ثمانيه عشر فاصله
ثلاثين شرقا اكثر المدن التي تضررت جراء
هذا الزلزال العنيف في تركيا هي غازي
عنتاب وديار بكر واضن وايضا ملطيه بينما
كانت اكثر مدن ومحافظات سوريا المتضرره هي
الواقعه شمالا مثل اعزاز اللاذقيه حماه
وحلب وبالاضافه الى طرطوس وامتدا اثر هذا
الزلزال ليشمل كل من لبنان والاردن وكذلك
العراق ودول مثل اليونان وقبرص وارمينيا
ايضا شعروا بهذا الزلزال
قلعه غازي عنتاب التاريخيه مشاهدينا وكما
ذكرنا قبل قليل ان مدينه غازي عنتاب من
المدن الاكثر تضررا من هذا الزلزال فهذه
القلعه التي تم بناؤها منذ اكثر من 2200
عام تعرضت الى الانهيار خلال الزلزال الذي
وقع في تركيا وبحسب ما افادت بعض وسائل
الاعلام التركيه ان قلعات غازيه عن تاب
التاريخيه تعرضت لاضرار جسيمه بسبب مركزها
الذي عرضها بشده للزلزال الذي جاء بقوه
تصل الى سبعه فاصله سبعه درجه فيما طبعا
لم يتم بعد تحديد الاضرار التي لحقت بهذا
الحصن الاثري
نشير الى هذا العدل العاجل الذي وردنا قبل
قليل مشاهدينا نتنياهو اشار وقال بانه
يعتقد بان المساعدات الاسرائيليه ستصل الى
سوريا قريبا وقعت انفجارات وحريق في قسمين
من خط انابيب للغاز في مدينه هاتاي
التركيه جراء الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب سوريا وكاله اخلاص
التركيه للانباء ذكرت ان السلطات التركيه
قررت تعليق توريد الغاز الى عدد من
المناطق الواقعه بالقرب من بؤر الهزات
الارضيه
ومن بين ضحايا زلزال الذي ضرب سوريا اعلن
الاتحاد الاوروبي لكره القدم عن وفاه
اللاعب الدولي السوري السابق نادر جوخدار
ونجله تاج جوخدار اثراء انهيار البناء
الذي يسكنه في مدينه جبل الساحليه نتيجه
الزلزال القوي والعنيف الذي ضرب من البلاد
جخ دار لاعبه بمركز الهجوم مع نادي الوثبه
ثم احترف مع الفيصلي والوحدات الاردنيين
حتى انتهاء مسيرته في عام 2008
في هذا العاجل الذي يردنا مشاهدينا يبدو
ان ضحايا الزلزال ارتفع عددهم الى 812
قتيلا في سوريا و14 قتيلا في تركيا حتى
الان وبحسب مراسلنا الاجزاء الاعداد في
تزايد اعداد المبانئ المنهاره ايضا في
تزايد ومن تحت الانقاض سماع نداء استغاثه
في مدينه جندريس بعرفين في محافظه حلب
التي تضررت اضرارا كبيره جراء الزلزال
[موسيقى]
في حلب ايضا اظهرت الصور في شارع بلال بحي
صلاح الدين انهيار مبنى بالكامل
نعود الى مراسلنا من اسطنبول زيدان زنكلو
زيدان يعني هل لك ان توصف لنا وضع الناس
في هذه الاجواء هل هم ما زالوا في حاله من
الذرع الذعر والهلع والصدمه ام بداوا
يستوعبون ما يحدث وبداوا يتمالكون انفسهم
وربما ايضا يحاولون تفادي اي تداعيات
قادمه من زلازل قادمه وهزات ارتداديه
متوقعه
كل الانبياء التي وقعتنا والاتصالات التي
اجريناها مع عديد الاشخاص الذين يتواجدون
في المناطق الجنوبيه وتحديدا في ولايه
غازي عنتاب تقريبا كل مراكز الايواء باتت
ممتلئه وحتى هناك اشخاص في الشارع يفضلون
بقاء في الشارع خشيه خشيه الهزات
الارتداديه التي تثير الرعب رغم الطقس
البارد جدا في جنوب تركيا او في عموم
تركيا وموجه الهواء البارد والثلوج التي
تحصل على عديد المناطق التركيه ما زال
البعض
يفضلون البقاء في الشارع على الذهاب
لمراكز الايواء خوفا من
هزات الارتداديه وايضا بسبب ان الزلزال
الثاني الذي وقع في تمام الساعه الواحده
والرابعه اي قبل حوالي ثلاث ساعات من الان
اثار الرعب بشكل كبير لدى سكان غازي عنتاب
رغم ان الزلزال كان في ولايه كهرمان مرعشه
لكن ارتداد الزلزال او الاثار التي خلفها
الزلزال كانت مخيفه في
مدينه غازي عنتاب وبالتالي زاد من حاله
الزعر لدى المواطنين هناك وبالتالي ادى
هذا او ادت هذه الحاله الى ان العديد من
الاشخاص لا يفضلون الذهاب الان الى الماوى
خوفا من الهزات بينما الانباء التي وصلتنا
من خلال الاشخاص الذين تواصلنا معهم
يفضلون البقاء او او كل تقريبا الاماكن
الماوى كانت مساجد او مدارس او حتى صالات
رياضيه ومراكز رياضيه تقريبا امتلات
بالمواطنين الذين تركوا منازلهم استجابه
لنداء السلطات التركيه التي تحذر بشكل
متكرر من عدم الدخول الى المباني التي
تشهد تشققات او تصدعات بسبب
الهزات الاعتداديه والخشيه ان تؤدي هذه
الهزات الى انهيار كامل او جزئي بهذه
المباني التي نجت من الزلزال الاول
والزلزال الثاني لكنها اصيبت بتصدعات
وتشققات
نتيجه قوه الزلزلين والهزازات الاعتداديه
التي تلاتهما طيب زيدان يعني ربما سؤالي
الاخير لك راينا تصريحاته مؤتمر صحفي
للرئيس تركيا رجب طيب اردوغان ونائبه كذلك
خرجوا وتحدثوا الى الناس هل من المتوقع ان
يخرجوا في مؤتمر اخر
للتحديثات والحديث عن المستجدات
زيدان يبدو انك لا تسمعني ولكن شكرا لك
مراسل العربيه من اسطنبول زيدان زنكلو اذا
مستمرون معكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
لهذه الكارثه والزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب
اسطنبول وامتدت داعيته الى الشمال السوري
وادى الى اكثر من 14 قتيل في تركيا واكثر
من 900 قتيل في سوريا